welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and the Loki finale fire the first
shots of the Great multiversal War among
the kangs and the mcu's Multiverse Saga
Loki transforms into the god of stories
weaving together his own green organic
Gil version of the Multiverse branches
to prove he remains wrong to allow his
friends to have free will but in doing
so leaves the infinite Kang variants on
the loose for the TVA to slowly follow
the trailer based on an interesting
Easter egg referencing the events of
Ant-Man the was Mania in the Loki
finale's closing minutes but there's
actually a lot more to pull from this
clue to learn the next steps of this
Multiverse crisis whether the next time
we see this war is going to be in Marvel
Studios Fantastic 4 the cast expected to
be announced in the next week or if
Marvel Studios decides to bring Loki
back for a third season despite what the
headwriter has said how far into the
Kang Dynasty did this Loki finale move
us announcement our live show in Los
Angeles on Thursday just got a bit
spicier with a very very very special
guests that we're working on booking
with these strikes ending a lot of stuff
is happening very fast at new rockstars
and we're working really hard to make
this event so so special we can't say
exactly what it is yet but trust me
you're going to want to book your
tickets past okay the Loki finale
episode allowed Loki to loop back on the
events of the season one finale when he
remains long-winded explanation to Loki
and Sylvie broke down and Sylvie just
decided to go through with killing he
remains we learned that all or most of
the events in season 2 really the whole
plot for rler and Miss Benn to deliver
the TVA handbook to Victor timley in the
19th century was he remains planned to
trap Loki in this kind of Doomsday
scenario with the loom so that Loki
would time slip over and over over again
to try to save it and failing that end
up slipping back to him he wanted an
equal who would see time the way he sees
time so that Loki would understand his
argument that the Universe needs a lone
caretaker controlling everything at the
end of time and to just let him do that
but our Loki now having lived for all
those additional centuries has picked up
some additional knowledge that he
remains didn't expect him to not just
the ability to pause time but an
appreciation for the Poetry of TS Elliot
that he remains doesn't share and a love
of his friends that isn't a selfish love
in which Loki would need to be able to
stay with them but a truly Selfless Love
In which Loki just wants them to be okay
with or without him that's what gives
Loki the new found confidence to trash
he remains under Ling equation and come
up with his own rules but he remains
warns as you may or may not know my
variants are already out there we'll
find them there's too many I won't stop
doesn't matter never stopped me
before I know CH I love the pacing of
this dialogue because it mirrors a chess
match a game we know he remains knows
well because he created Mis minutes
initially as a chess partner in this
rematch with Loki he remains assumed
that he was controlling the board but
when Loki by dropping that tslot quote
and by pausing time turns the table on
he remains and whereas before the
conversation was dominated by pauses and
slow deliberate exchanges now it speeds
up we'll find them there's too many I
won't stop it doesn't matter never
stopped me before I know champ it's
paced like a rapid series of moves
between two Chess Masters clearing each
other's pawns and Rooks and Bishops and
knights smacking that button in between
and when he he remains says champ he is
realizing he is in check by trapping
Loki for centuries he remains has made
the same mistake doramu made with Dr
Strange never underestimate the resolve
of a wizard you cannot scale the
infinite Doctor Strange proved that so
long as he had that time Stone he could
Loop for as long as it took to wear
doramu down and Loki proves the same
thing round and round and round we go he
remains later says Loki is willing to
sacrifice his own connections to his
friends to isolate himself in order to
keep he remains from oppressing the
Universe this video was sponsored by
Helix sleep who has cyberweek deals
available now with up to 25% off your
purchase for a limited time and look I
get it finding the perfect mattress can
be difficult but helix's sleep quiz
makes it so easy you just take the quiz
and Helix finds the perfect mattress for
you I wanted a medium firm mattress with
lumbar support that sleeps cool and I
got matched with the dusk Lux Helix
mattress Helix delivers your mattress
right to your door with free shipping in
the US the mattress comes rolled up in a
box and is super easy to set up yourself
Helix has a 100 night sleep trial so you
get get more than 3 months to make sure
that you love your mattress Helix
mattresses have a 10-year warranty Helix
even offers financing options and
flexible payment plans so a great night
sleep is never far away I love my Helix
mattress I think you would too if you're
looking for a new bed check out Helix
sleep they have great cyberweek deals
available now it's a perfect time to
update your sleep with 25% off a helix
mattress plus two free pillows click the
link below or go to helixsleep.com
rockstars to find out more about this
limited time offer so he remain says
that his variants are already out and
we've seen a bit of that from Quantum
Mania Kang the Conqueror in the quantum
realm and the countless others in the
Council of kangs in that Arena IM mortis
farat Scarlet Centurian and probably
that's Mr Griffin in there too these are
loose kangs throughout the time stream
or the branches of the time tree we
should say that the TVA is now
investigating while the tva's new
Mission seems to be nurture our nature
and keep the multiple branches of the
time tree thriving there is some Pest
Control still necessary Mobius and B15
share this report I got those reports on
the variance of he
remains do any of them know that we
exist yet nope I guess one of them
caused a little bit of a ruckus on 616
adjacent realm but they handled it so
we're all good for now that's all we can
ask for 616 adjacent realm refers of
course to the quantum Realm of the 616
universe and this report describes the
events of Ant-Man in the was quantum
media these photos show Kang to
conqueror blasting the Freedom Fighters
and his time chair that he was traveling
in and initially crash landed in the
quantum realm I began to break down this
paperwork in the break down but I have
since made some more of it out so at the
top of this for it reads risk report
threat identification this isn't like
the paperwork we saw in season one that
listed apocalyptic events this is a risk
report a threat the top lines are for
variant number name location in temporal
Aura and right beside that the first
time in the series we see the Alias Kang
written in quotes beneath that are
powers unidentified and then related
case files and based on the bleeding of
the ink that was added to this form by
Mobius is typewriter and the way this
ink bleeds it seems to bleed more more
for numbers like8 and six it seems to be
there are 12 other cases listed 12 other
logged incidents of he remains variant
that the TBA has logged thus far so why
do Mobius and B15 list these as related
cases well as of now they may consider
all Kang variants connected since they
are variants of he remains but in the
quantum Mania mid credit scene the top
three referred to Kang the Conqueror as
quote the exiled one so it must have
been a kind of vote by the council which
in the tva's eyes may kind of connect
all of these kangs in a kind of case the
event report section has the most text
that I'm still trying to make out but
I'm pretty sure the Top Line reads
figure one apprehended for an energy
Forge consistent with proprietary
technology figure one referring to Kang
in the accompanying photo in the case
File and the other photo which would be
figure two depicts the energy Forge in
question so from these words alone we
can already determine that Kang the
conqueror's time chair was likely based
on what the TVA considers to be
proprietary technology of theirs and I'm
going to assume that it is a technology
that would would now be in the TVA
handbook second edition that OB has
printed crediting himself and Victor
timley why do they need a second edition
well because Victor timely by joining
this TVA has given them new information
he wants to include therefore this
second edition must have that multiplier
Tech that timely contributed that sphere
with the gears and the cogs that looks
like a smaller version of Kang's time
chair from quamania so basically Kang
the Conqueror was a Kang who stole that
technology and turned it into a mobile
vehicle to stay on the move into a
invade all the other kangs and the TVA
now Eric Martin said that they conceive
seasons 1 and two as two halves of a
book and don't have plans for a season 3
which I totally understand and if that
ends up being the case I'm perfectly
satisfied with what we've gotten so far
but there are enough unanswered
questions from this show like what
happens to Ren Slayer now what is the
true origin of Miss minutes and what is
the TVA doing now that I think there
could be a lowkey season 3 in which TVA
agents investigate a Kang of the weak
like Kang Dynasty isn't coming until
2026 so just like imagine an agent of
Shield style Loki TVA case File spin-off
Series 2 years from now in which each
episode is a Prelude origin story of
each of the other members of the Kang
Dynasty that the Avengers have to fight
in that film this form that Mobius hands
B15 could give us the 12 episodes of
such a series hey comment down below
with what you would like a Loki season 3
or a spin-off series to look like
support us with our OB inspired shirt
we're all going to die at nerd. shop you
can follow me on all socials at eav
subscribe to all three channels in the
new rockstars Network thanks so much for
watching I'll see you next time
[Music]
bye